Let us discuss data sources
in the health care industry.
So the industry is data-rich,
but data may be hard to access.
Sometimes it involves
unstructured data
like doctor's notes.
Often the data is hard
to get due to differences
in technology.
Hospitals in southern
Massachusetts versus California
might use different technologies
and different platforms.
Finally there are strong
privacy laws, HIPAA,
around health care data sharing.
So what is available?
Claims data is a major source.
Claims data are requests
for reimbursement submitted
to insurance companies or
state-provided insurance
from doctors, hospitals
and pharmacies.
Another source of data is
the eligibility information
for employees.
And finally demographic
information: gender and age.
Let me give you some
examples on claims data.
So this shows six
different claims.
Let's consider this one.
So this is the provider's name.
The corresponding
diagnostic code.
This is about upper
respiratory disorders.
This is another code
associated with the diagnosis.
This is the scientific
term for the diagnosis.
The specific code again.
This was an office visit, and
it's an established patient.
The date.
And the amount of money that
was claimed by the physician.
Others claims are similar.
As we see, the claims data is
a rich, structured data source.
It is very high dimensional.
For example, claims
involving diagnosis
involve thousands
of different codes.
Similarly with drugs, where
there are tens of thousands,
and procedures.
However, this collection
of data does not
capture all aspects of a
person's treatment or health.
Many things must be inferred.
Unlike electronic
medical records,
we do not know the
results of a test,
only that the test
was administered.
For example, we do not know
the results of a blood test,
but we do know that the
blood test was administered.
The specific exercise we are
going to see in this lecture
is an analytics approach
to building models starting
with 2.4 million people
over a three year span.
The observation period
was 2001 to 2003.
This is where this
data is coming from.
And then out of sample,
we make predictions
for the period of 2003 and 2004.
This was in the early
years of D2Hawkeye.
Out of the 2.4 million people,
we included only people
with data for at least 10
months in both periods,
both in the observation
period and the results period.
This decreased the
data to 400,000 people.